My name is Eric Hippeau,
I'm a venture capitalists.
My firm is called Larry Hippeau ventures
where it's me plus three other partners.
We are technology investors.
So we look for companies that use
technology,
primarily consumer technology.
It doesn't mean that they have to be
consumer facing,
but the technology has to be based on
the same technology that we all use day
to day.
Uh,
and so we're looking for companies that
use technology to either create large
new marketplaces or large new
businesses,
uh,
or who disrupt a large businesses that
are already in place.
Um,
and New York is particularly well suited
for this because there's a lot of people
with very diverse backgrounds,
diverse domain knowledge.
Uh,
we have a lot of people in the,
in our educational system,
a million kids in our public school
system,
$600,000 car students,
um,
and technology today is primarily
developed in large urban centers.
So obviously New York is well positioned
for that.
The,
the difference between New York and
Silicon Valley is in the kind of
technology that people that we develop
here as opposed to in Silicon Valley
first.
I think we should point out where the
similarities are and the similarities
are that because technology today is
transportable and rentable and
relatively cheap,
uh,
to,
to use,
uh,
we in New York,
but it could be anywhere,
it could be Bombay,
could be Austin,
have access to the same technology to
develop new applications,
new services than anybody in Silicon
Valley.
So everyone starts with the same level
playing field.
The technology is accessible through the
cloud.
It's rentable through the cloud.
Anybody can start a company with a
couple of,
of,
of laptops and a two or three people and
you have an,
a few thousand dollars literally,
and you can start a company and you can
start a business.
So it's very different today than it was
just a few years ago where a large part
of the money that you raised actually
went to the acquisition of the
technology.
You had to buy servers and you have to
buy hardware,
you had to buy expensive software
licenses.
And today you don't have to do any of
that.
So that's a big difference.
But,
um,
we,
we have in New York as,
as,
as anywhere else access to the same
latest developments in technology than
anybody in Silicon Valley.
The big differences that New York
focuses more on the software layer,
on the application and the services
layer.
Um,
so that we're really good at software,
New York.
We,
we,
uh,
we're good at,
um,
at platforms.
We're good at consumer facing
application.
We're good at,
um,
enterprise software,
software as a service.
We're good at a variety of different
domains,
obviously are the ones that you can
think of the traditional sectors such as
advertising and media and uh,
but also healthcare and a variety of
different domains where you have people
who have experience and expertise,
uh,
because they know some big companies are
located here and big sectors of the
economy or are based here.
What New York,
um,
it's probably not going to do is develop
the next plumbing for the Internet.
That's more likely to be a coming out of
the west coast.
But having said that,
we're increasingly getting more and more
advanced engineering talent are in New
York.
In fact,
uh,
on Roosevelt Island,
there's going to be a cornell university
in,
in conjunction with the big technology
institute in Israel are building a
campus and which will be ready in two or
three years,
but the classes have already started in
other locations and this is all going to
be advanced applied engineering.
So who knows what's going to develop in
the future.
Some hardware is already being developed
in New York.
We invest investors,
for instance,
in Makerbot,
the three d printer company that was
sold recently to,
um,
another three d printer company.
So,
uh,
so there is a,
there is a background in,
in hardware and manufacturing in New
York,
but generally speaking,
it's really software that's,
um,
that's the,
the big thing as it were healing.